avec stéphane explique gilet jaune
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct ce matin sur rtl france la
semaine passée on a compté 168
manifestation
en province au total plus de trente deux
mille personnes dans la capitale 5200
personnes selon les chiffres officiels
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
cette journée elle va mobiliser encore
plus bien comme il ya encore des
nouvelles mesures là je m'aperçois que
mon pass moi j'avais malheureusement
hugo vite donc au mois deux ans début
janvier donc j'espère être tranquille
jusqu'à en juillet 20 visible ans soit
jusqu'en avril s'il existe donc de deux
mois la validité quand on a obtenu phare
eu l'oeil locaux vides donc oui
malheureusement il faut continuer à
maintenir la pression sur le
gouvernement qui prend des mesures tout
aussi absurde et on voit donc ses neuf
volonté délibérée d'une manipulation de
masse on est dans une guerre de
communication et donc c'est laissé à ses
mesures prises sont là plutôt pour
diviser la population toujours maintenu
la pression sur la population et que
cette population a peur c'est la
gouvernance par la peur et donc il faut
en relation manifester et continuer à
maintenir la pression mais c'est pas
suffisant efforts et b roy d'autres
moyens aussi à mettre la pression sur le
gouvernement je crois que vous vous ne
manifestez plus maintenant fait ça alors
j'ai dit qu'elle a beaucoup de
manifestations j'ai déclaré l'acteur 14
et 15 chez les jaunes a donc en 2019
j'ai déterré encore cet été des
manifestations donc sur ainsi le je suis
actuellement et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
tellement de répression déjà dans les
deux cas du mouvement des légions donc
ça faisait surtout peur aux gens c'était
l'objectif de ces deux sets lui ces
mutilations de faire peur aux gens et
qu'ils ne viennent pas à nouveau à
manifester est là donc il y avait
ensuite avec new york où vivent beaucoup
plus donc dodd cette fois des as monde
donc
en 2019 je pourrais dire j avais pas
peur là j'ai pas compte non plus mais
c'est vrai c'est assez lassant de
recevoir donc quinze jours après une
manifestation même quand on n'a pas été
interpellé un petit papillon vert avec
une amende à 135 euros pour non port de
masques etc etc je retrouvais donc des
prétextes complètement fallacieux et les
mêmes débile pour donc mettre cette
pression sur la population et décourager
à manifester je suis pas découragé de
manifester mais moi j'ai engage d'autres
d'autres actions et donc c'est vrai que
j'ai assez d'amour j'ai une trentaine
d'amande j'ai une trentaine de procès
également pour des actes que j ai commis
par ailleurs hors manifestation et donc
j'ai assez d'éléments ont été jugés en
cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
là je peux vous dire j'ai sept dossiers
également donc en cour de cassation j'ai
encore joué encore déposer un mémoire
mardi prochain en cour de cassation
puisque j'ai donc cherché à contester
les amendes en premier niveau donc à ça
monte encore de cassation et donc je
vais aller jusqu'à cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour dénoncer
justement où toute cette pression qui
est mise sur la population toute cette
oppression c'est une oppression d'état
on vous reproche cas d'actes justement
c'est là par exemple pour
d'aider les actions que j'ai commise
donc bien sûr j'aime provoquer pouvoir
j'ai fait des tags sur sur l'assemblée
nationale sur le medef j'ai le provoquer
macron par d'emploi quand tu y étais à
besançon sont à omar qui m'a fait un
procès qui a perdu en nullité d'ailleurs
à toulon l'année dernière là j'ai
regagné à nouveau un procès contre macro
j'ai décroché en doublant d'une
manifestation déclarée à besançon j'ai
décroché le portrait de macron dans
l'hôtel de ville j'ai déchiré et j'ai
déposé des déchets dans le final de
judiciaire de besançon où j'ai
revendiqué mon acte j'ai également dans
cet été donc décroché pendant d'état
pour rapper 1 lors de manifestations
déclarées à annecy j'ai toujours
revendiqué les attaques jeux faits
devant la police d'ailleurs et donc ça
me vaut des procédures etc à besançon
vous avez un juge justement j'ai reçu
récemment donc le jugement et donc qui
m'a relaxé d'avoir déchiré le portrait
de 9,90 de macron à besançon on a des
juges parfois qui osent défier justement
leur hiérarchie et donc il faut arriver
à plaider à la barre justement que nous
sommes en résistance à l'oppression que
c'est un usurpateur qui à la tête de
l'étape s'il arrivait pas pardon kruse
médiatique au pouvoir et donc il faut
arriver à contester tous ces éléments
dire que nos gestes sont politiques et
donc à partir de ce moment là quand on
est une oppression est en face de nous
un pouvoir pratiquement mafieuse je
dirais pour en tout cas sous l'emprise
mafieuses qui n'écoute plus la rue et
bien c'est devant les tribunaux qu'il
faut essayer de s'exprimer politiquement
est d'arriver à avoir des petites
victoires de ce site donc comme moi tout
le monde comme moi
cette question un
bon vous contestez évidemment le pass
vaccinale
à cela s'ajoute on imagine la perte de
validité du certificat de rétablissement
il ya trois cortèges distincts
aujourd'hui dans la capitale pour
quelles raisons pourquoi ne pas
manifester ensemble puisque vous
contestez se passe vaccinale et on
imagine aussi cette mesure concernant la
validité du certificat de rétablissement
et pour ça je ne fais plus de
manifestations à paris autant que
déclarant moi je ça me dérange pas
qu'ils aient trois manifestations
éventuellement ce qui me dérange c'est
qu'elle ce neveu convergent pas et s'il
y avait une convergence éventuellement
en direction
des points un peu différent avec cette
convergent par exemple maire du 7e
arrondissement
ça se rapproche d'une nissan à santé ce
serait très fort justement vous n'êtes
pas forcément des cortèges donc dans le
même cortège même moi si j'avais des
filets par exemple la mi juillet à paris
dans le cortège de filippo mais il y
avait donc un gilet jaune qui avait
déclaré le même parcours et donc ça
neutraliser un petit peu à l'extrême
droite isme de filippo en faisant un
cortège unique il y avait également des
gilet jaune mais quand on est arrivé au
final philippot avec tous récupérés et
ça c'était très désagréable donc on peut
comprendre qu'on ne fasse pas le même
pas le même parcours mais par contre ce
qui est extrêmement dommage il en voit
bien sur votre carte vous avez le
troisième parcours qui s'éloigne de
l'autre et donc c'est bien dommage qu'il
n'y ait pas de convergence même qu'on
n'est pas quand enfin converger et après
que par patrice sauvage mais quand on se
disperse et on a convergé vers un lieu
un petit peu identique vers forcément il
y aura un petit peu de bazar et c'est un
peu normal quand il ya une manifestation
qu'il y avait eu de débordements c'est
bien l'objectif d'une manifestion
contestataires je dis pas qu'il faut
tout casser mais c'est normal qu'ils
aient des débordements et pascal
bruxelles quand on voit que le bâtiment
de
jeu vous aurez les hébergements sans
violence
c'est ce qui a été reconnu à besançon
j'ai fait un débordement décrochant le
portel macron et donc j'ai déchiré et
donc le juge a précisé qu'il ya pas eu
de violence physique et c'est donc faux
s'est passé et moi ce qui me voilà ce
qui m'a vraiment me gêne dans les
manifestations c'est de s'en prendre aux
policiers je trouve c'est complètement
inutile c'est complètement c'est ce
qu'ils veulent juste en ciel que pouvoir
veut voir des français ça monthey et moi
ça me rend ça serge mal au coeur de voir
ça et donc c'est pas les policiers qu'il
faut qu'il faut provoquer il faut
essayer de montrer qu'on a un objectif
or c'est peut-être le ministère de la
santé se rapprocher ministère la santé
pour montrer qu'on n'est pas content et
donc après les policiers par son faux
alibi esquivé mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
une provocation de leur part et sur
laquelle il ne faut pas riposter c'est
très difficile merci beaucoup à vous
steph alès mais je rappelle que vous
êtes gilet jaune ans